- Five fun physics phenomena. Number one,
have a friend hold a cane out horizontally
for you, or another similar object. And putting
your two index fingers together, try to place
them underneath the center of mass. When they
let go, you will find it doesn't normally
work. But now try putting each index finger
at opposite ends of the cane, and then moving
your index fingers in towards the middle.
What you will find is that they always end
up right under the center of mass of the cane.
You can try starting off asymmetrically and
they will still end up under the center of
mass. You can try going at different speeds.
Really slowly, or really fast. But you still
end up perfectly under the center of mass.
How does this work? Number two, the phone
flip. Have you ever tried to spin your phone?
If you do it in this direction, it's pretty
easy. It stays nicely aligned. If you spin
it along its short axis, you'll also find
it spins very well. But if you try to flip
your phone end over end like this, you can't
do it cleanly. The phone will never flip simply
end over end without also rotating in one
of the other directions. Even when I make
an almost perfect flip, instabilities grow
until the phone rotates around another axis.
Why can't... No, I still can't do it. Why
is it so? Number three, you've probably seen
that if you rub a cup on your hair, you can
make it electrically charged. And if you bring
it close to a stream of water, you can actually
cause that stream to deflect. Now usually
this is used in chemistry textbooks as a demonstration
of the polar nature of water. Water is a molecule
with a more positive side and a more negative
side, and so what happens, so you're told,
is that the water molecule flips around so
the positive side of the water faces the negative
side of the cup and that is what attracts
the water to the cup. But this is not the
real explanation. If you have a uniform electric
field, there's an equal force pulling the
positive side towards it as there is pushing
the negative side away from it. And so you
can't actually do more than just turn the
molecules. You would need a really, really
strong gradient in your electric field to
make this work at all, and it basically is
just not going to happen from a cup. So why
is the stream actually attracted to a charged
cup? That is the question. Number four, take
a piece of your favorite cereal and drop it
into a bowl of water. Then using a very strong
magnet, try to pull the cereal around. Isn't
that cool? So why is cereal magnetic? And
finally, five, the teabag rocket. Take a teabag
and cut off the sealed end very carefully.
Now dump out the tea. Form the teabag into
a square column. And balance it on the plate.
Now light the top of the teabag on fire. Try
to light it evenly on all sides. Get ready
for takeoff in three, two, one. Ha, yeah!
That is the beauty of the teabag rocket. So
why did that happen? So how do all of these
phenomena work? Let me know in the comments
or make a video explaining any or all of them.
Or subscribe to the channel and I'll post
the answers next week. I hope you enjoyed
those fun physics phenomena. I know a guy
who would, the former commander of the international
space station, Commander Chris Hadfield. I'm
actually hosting live events with him in late
August in Sydney and Canberra. I'm so looking
forward to that. Now, the Sydney shows are
all sold out, but there are still as of now
tickets to the Canberra show. So if you want
to come to that, check out the link in the
description. Now Chris Hadfield actually wrote
a book called An Astronaut's Guide to Life
on Earth, and I'm listening to it right now
as I travel around the world, and it is awesome
because it contains great advice not only
for people who want to become astronauts,
but also for everyone who wants to lead a
meaningful life here on earth. And you can
download this book for free if you like by
going to audible.com/veritasium. Or you can
pick any other book of your choosing for a
one month free trial. Audible is a great service
with over 150,000 titles in all areas of literature,
including fiction, non-fiction, and periodicals,
and so you can find virtually anything you
want there. And by going to audible.com/veritasium,
they know that I sent you and they help me
out to continue making these videos for you
for free. So I really want to thank Audible
for supporting me and I want to thank you
for watching.